and we should say congratulations
euforio you won an emmy hey
i know
and that was the
that was that kind of proper lockdown
lockdown yeah so where were you i was in
my living room okay i was in my living
room and it was um it was actually
really special because i think you know
had it not been done that way that year
i wouldn't have been able to have my
whole family with me so i did it in my
living room
my mom's back there you can't see in
this picture but her face is like this
my nieces my little niece my dog
runs out from under the table when
everybody starts screaming um it was uh
it was really really special so i got to
share with them which i couldn't imagine
doing that any other way and if i had
done it
all like in a real
like audience like this in front of
everyone i would have i'd i would just
would have
probably thrown up i don't know what i
was like
i was so nervous but this was the one
wasn't where so
how many there must be five nominees
yeah i think i believe so five nominees
best actress in a drama yes um but there
was someone outside everyone's house yes
in a hazmat suit that like looked like a
tuxedo it was actually really cute um
but what's not cute is everyone
no matter like all the nominees someone
would be in front of their house in the
hazmat suit with an emmy
and if yeah like that
and if you didn't get it
they would just drive
[Applause]
[Music]
you